With transformative technology and at
the transformative technology lab,
we're tracking 10 major areas of Trans
Tech and those 10 areas include things
like neurofeedback and biofeedback,
neurostim and bio stem.
Those are the ones that I think people
would think of the most.
A good example of that would be the Muse
headset by interacts on that measures
your eeg,
so measures your brain waves.
Another thing that's coming out is a
neuro stem.
A good example of that would be a
company called Halo neuroscience,
and so it's a.
it's a.
it's a slight stimulation to the brain
that in their trials with elite
athletes,
they're showing people having big surges
in ability and so that's kind of
interesting.
There's another product called think
that sits on the forehead right here and
it stimulates the peripheral nerves and
short of it could replace a cup of
coffee so it sort of stimulates you and
wakes you up.
So there's a lot of focus on things that
are taking feedback from the body and
then stimulating the body.
And so it could be the body or the
brain.
One of the things that is coming is a
lot of vegas nerve stimulation and I'm
the on the medical side,
there's research that's recently come
out where people are really taking that
more seriously.
Um,
in addition,
some of the things that I think are
really cool is I'm really intrigued by
emotion recognition software,
whether that's through cameras that are
watching facial expressions eye or
through,
um,
or another example would be there's a
company called beyond verbal that just
off of the audio files can pick up human
emotion.
And you might think,
well,
you know,
sort of what's the use of that?
I know how I feel,
but it's actually,
if you think about it,
when everything in your house is smart,
you're really going to want to want it
to know if you're upset or sad or not.
You know,
if you're upset or not.
So,
you know,
I have a friend,
an older friend that I bought an Amazon
Echo for and she whispers around the
echo,
like it's a real person.
This is someone who's in there who's in
their seventies.
And so for people who are growing up in
smart houses,
which you know a lot of children today,
they won't even know a time where there
isn't a certain level of intelligence
that's baked into their environment.
We're going to want all these things to
know how we feel.
I think that emotion recognition is
really interesting.
It's the thing that's captured my
imagination right now.
There's a lot of interest right now in
neuro stem and a lot of that is based on
a series of studies that were done by
Darpa where they were using slight
electrical stimulation and saw a
increase in task acquisition for people
in various roles in the military.
The one that's the most well known is
for the increase or the acceleration for
sharp shooters from novice to expert
with the application of a slight
electrical stimulation while they were
learning.
There's a lot of people who are really
interested in that.
There's actually a really large do it
yourself community around the world
where people are doing citizen
independent science really and do it
yourself science and using various
levels of electrical currency on their
own brains.
And then sharing it in forums and
communicating about it.
People have been trying electrical
stimulation with physical task
acquisition,
also language tests acquisition.
It's one of those things that there's
products that are being based on it.
Um,
there's a whole category of things with
a called transcranial direct
stimulation.
And so there's a lot of products out
there on that.
Some of the brand names that you might
find would be focus is one.
Halo neuroscience is another,
the think product is another.
And so it's starting to have commercial
products for it.
Um,
there also was a,
as you can imagine,
there's a lot of the medical community
is a little concerned about it.
It's a good example of where people,
individuals are really sort of pushing
ahead of where the medical community is
on,
you know,
what's a good idea for what levels of
stimulation you should have,
how often and where,
you know,
what part of the,
of the brain that you try to stimulate
through the surface.
And so it's really,
it's a,
it's an interesting space and people are
pushing into it.